you
my name is Keri Chisholm my name is
byron spice hi my name is Clea my name
is cheryl platt said my name is Brad
Myers I'm an watzmann my name is drew
Davidson and I was at the last lecture
and I was at the last lecture and I was
at the last lecture what was being there
like crazy
there's a very big crowd I think bigger
than they expected some of my former
students who had known him for many
years
flew in especially for the lecture it
was it was a charged atmosphere a little
bit of you know sadness because
everybody knew that this was his last
lecture but he came out and he
absolutely shocked everybody and he said
I'm sorry if you thought I was going to
be ill I'm sorry to disappoint you and I
think we were actually one of the last
like set of people to actually get into
it there was like literally the fire
marshal was there what stuck with me was
the impact he managed to have just
sharing his experiences you always left
with the courage that Randy displayed he
was always a very open guy always very a
showman I really like that I get kind of
a reminder of this when I'm on campus is
that the brick walls are there to show
us how much we want something I think
that the grandi did a lot not just for
Carnegie Mellon which for the city of
Pittsburgh I think it was recognition of
him that brought more recognition to
Pittsburgh but the power of just a
simple really well delivered lecture
like to this day has an impact
their story you want to share and I said
oh I'm from Pittsburgh Pennsylvania I
work for a university they're called
Carnegie Mellon and she said well
Carnegie Mellon that's where Randy
Pausch was from and she proceeds to tell
me about how she watched the last
lecture and like just thought it was
such a great story and I told her that I
was there and you know we it was just
she was amazed and we had this
connection you know in Athens Greece and
it was just incredible
that people call in because they've
heard about the last lecture and they
want out you know you knew Annie tell me
about him or like I want to come to
school even though I've never been to
school ever and I'm like well you need
to get an undergraduate degree and we're
at graduate program and they're like oh
you're the brick wall the the story went
so big in the news media we were in The
Wall Street Journal a Roman Good Morning
America which no one really had expected
and I think from that point on you know
Randy probably could spent the rest of
his life just doing interviews that's
all I did for two years was communicate
with the entire world people called me
from Ecuador is there anything that I
can do for Randy why do you think it's
important the first year students see
him you have the chance to read the book
and so I think with students coming in
and reading that book what I think feels
so seeing you about that is there's a
lot of acknowledgement about what's
important about seeing you and I think a
big part of that is just our community I
think that it's nice that they get to
read it because then they get to know
about Randy Randy was ultimately CMU at
the core of working in an
interdisciplinary environment is
understanding that problems are bigger
than any one person and you need other
people's expertise to create something
bigger than than any one of you could
have individually one of the things but
Carnegie Mellon is is
people here address problems in the real
world and you don't get much realer than
you know how do you live your life and
how do you ultimately face death it's
it's talking about how you can be your
best self you know and Carnegie Mellon
is the kind of place that challenges you
to be the best that you can be just so
you're thinking about it 10 years is to
us a lot we were thinking is less about
sort of a memorial and more about like a
celebration but but seldom do people
really outside the university get to
know a professor in the the almost
intimate way that people got to know
Randy if you want it badly enough you
could overcome almost any obstacle and I
think that's the thing that stays with
me
and I hope that that's one of the
messages that the young people who read
this book come away with when they come
to Carnegie Mellon you work hard and
there's nothing that's beyond your reach
nothing that's beyond your grasp
[Music]
[Applause]
you